TO GET THE START FOR THE
ISLANDERSEHIND FOR CHARGE.: THAE
PLAY ALL HAPPENE THE
DRAW.
AGAINST BROCK NELSON.
THE PUCK COMES OUT T .
THIS WILL BE ICING AGAINST THE
R
DOBSON.ARA.
ERIKSSON E TO THE PARISE FAMILY.
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH HISRONT
ORGANIZATION.
NOT ONLY THE FACT THAT THEY ARE,
SOMETIMES COMMUNICATION.
NEW PLAYERS ON THE DEFENDED BY
ROSTER TO GET YOUNGER.
IN PREVIOUS PERIOD.
FOLIGNO BACKTRACKING.
DISRUPTING THE ISLANDERS
DO.
OUTSTANDING GOALTENDING.
THEY ARE SECUTIVE
AWAY FROM HOME. ICE.
JUST AFTER CHIPPING ALONG THE
WALL, GET IT INTO THE OFFENSIVEO
BACK INTO THE LINEUP MOVES
ZUCCARELLO.
BLOCK IS
BARZAL IN THE
SIX -- FOLIGNO JUMPS
STURM GOES OFF OF THE BOARDS.
GIFTS TO BJUSGSTAD.
BJUSUS BIG SAVE BY
KAHKONEN KEEPING THIS A ONE-GOAL
GAME.
NET.
I THINK THE WILD HAVE BEEN A
INTO THE CORNER, DUHAIME LOW, S,
VARLAMOV.
MINNESOTA
HOME FOR MINNESOTA!
>> Wes: WHAT A CAGEY LITTLE
NEED ME TO PLAY WIN?
THAT IS OKAY TOO PLAYED MY GAME
AIN'T GOING TO 3-2, MINNESOTA.
>> Wes: BRANDON DUHAIME GOT
HIS GOAL TAKEN AWAY FROM HIM
EARLIER IN THE GAME,
WENT JUST .
ERIKSSON EK REVERSESEACH PLUS TN
INTO THE MIDDLE, WAHLSTROM.
NOW BARZAL.
GREAT STICK BY THIS IS WHAT A TS
ALL ABOUT!
LOOK AT ALL FOUR PLAYERS GOING
UP
>> Anthony: BARZAL COMES TO
CENTER.
AND